hello mystery guest number two here on
this busy thursday
on the rich eisen show hello now now
rich you know i ain't never been no
mystery
[Laughter]
how could i be a mystery ghost goats and
goats are not mysteries this mr
october on the phone line right now
thank you
[Applause]
i'm surprised it took you that long come
on reg
you're you know you're the reason why i
love baseball reggie jackson that's a
fact
that's a fact and you're the reason why
why i watch uh your football show
yeah nfl i don't know what it's called
but day morning
yes i will call that that's by the way
you have no idea by the way reggie
jackson is here uh
on the rich eisen show you have no idea
reggie when
i get a text from you during nfl game
day morning
and i tell the guys what you are saying
um
what a tremendous boost it gives
everybody on the set that's a fact
oh yeah you you have such a great crew
there with uh uh kurt being the straight
man
and then the other guys in between uh um
the coach yes um i know i know well i'll
tell i'll tell i'll tell mariucci and
invariably your text is like tell irv to
pipe down and get off of kurt's back
that's usually what your texts are like
it's like
like uh michael
dallas stinks don't
think you realize that don't you haven't
you woken up to that yet
wake up brother you're still sleeping
now
he must live near disneyland because he
dreams that they're good
well he just he just came on last hour
uh reg and for my birthday uh i asked
him to
give me the gift of him predicting the
cowboys record game by game
and he said they're gonna go 13-4 this
year
yeah tell him if he keeps doing that
we're going to have it tested
[Laughter]
now for a full disclosure you're you're
a steelers fan right reggie
correct sir yes now what's what's the
genesis of that again
pittsburgh franco harris and i became
friends probably 50
i'm 75 uh i think i was probably
22 24
uh and hank i'm three years or three or
four years older than franco
but uh we've been friends for over 50
years
and uh so you know when he came and
played against the raiders
i don't even know how we became friends
i think it was because of this thing
called super teams
in 1972 when when we uh played against
each other you know the tug of war and
all that kind of stuff it was the
steelers and the a's
and the two steelers and the a's were
always in the super teams because
we won three years in a row row and they
won like four out of six or something
you know because again that's amazing
reggie too and uh something to bring up
here
um that you were you know part of the
great a's teams before you were part of
the
great yankees teams what could can you
walk me through i've never asked you
this
what was it like hitting that light
tower in tiger
i was named as an alternate i had 17
home runs was hitting 280 something at
the time maybe 45 or 650 rbis
and tony oliva got hurt in oakland
he was hitting 400 and so he got hurt
i took his place and i was dressing
a salvando and i dressed next to each
other catfish was on the other side was
sow
empty locker reggie empty locker catfish
and so i'm getting ready for the
all-star game
packing my bag and south says reggie he
said they called me buck when i was
playing
[ __ ] whatever you do don't embarrass us
and strike out
so you know he said because you'll
probably be a pitch hitter so i get to
get to the all-star game and buy the
blues kitchen and he got hit hard in the
first inning
and i pinch hit for a vita in like the
second
inning and i was saying god almighty
earl weaver
to myself why don't you save me for a
big moment
you're gonna get rid of me so early i
don't even count
and so i i obviously i didn't say that
but my ego was working on my brain
i guess i get the hand plate and within
three pitches
it's a ball and two strikes and i
stepped out of the battle's box and i
just had some brand new bats made
by adirondack but joe torrey's brother
joe torre was the third baseman for the
national league
and joe torrey's brother frank torrey uh
was a senior executive at rawlings and
he took care of some special bats he
made me some special bats back
that day 35 and a half inches long and
the handle was certain xyz but it was 37
and a half ounces
and so i stepped out of the batter's box
and i said damn
sal says not the strikeout that's what
was on my mind
one ball and two strikes and so i choked
up a half an inch and i hadn't choked up
i didn't choke up before that even in
little league
and i never choked up after that i
choked up one inch or half an inch
got that at that and bingo uh
i hit the ball up over the stadium over
the roof but it hit the
light stanchion and i kind of surprised
myself because the ball just jumped off
the bat the wind was blown out
um and i rounded the bases like i was
king kong i felt so good
willie mccovey was on first days and
um ernie banks was a short stop and tori
was a third
johnny bench was catching and i just
really felt so good
because all those guys were my idols and
uh
i'd done something pretty good i didn't
really know how far the ball went i
didn't why you know i kind of watched it
but i lost sight of it
right but you did rounding the bases you
were aware it hit the lights right
at tiger stadium uh you were not no i
wasn't i thought the ball went over the
roof
because the light love light tower sat
on top of the roof
and and you i hit the ball halfway up
into the light
around the generators and this there was
a fence there
and so i thought for sure that the ball
went over the roof because i
i'd hit a ball over the roof there
before you know down the line
right so what did you say reg what did
you say to sal bando and you saw him
again what'd you say to him
i didn't say anything it was just uh you
know everybody had congratulated me it's
such a great job
and i would say that home run since 1971
gets mentioned 50 times a year to me
in the last and that's 1971 so you got
29 and 20. yep you got almost 60 years
when i've heard about it damn
reg i mean i never get tired of it bro
ah
reggie jackson here on the rich eisen
show and out of that story
reggie that that i take away from that
is that
once upon a time it was an embarrassment
to strike out
that actually nowadays man right i mean
it is just a
totally different ball of wax well i i
struck out
2 597 times
and if you take that by 2021
it's about 130 strikeouts a year
and i had years 140 150 135
160 most i ever struck out was 170 my
first
year but from there i probably
in full seasons was good for 137 to 140
and now you have lead off hitters that
strike out that much
and you have a promotion in the game
they promote because the analytics
decipher that you should swing
up and that's crazy
you need to learn to find the baseball
first with the barrel
before you start trying to swing up
that's what people don't understand you
have guys with natural swings
that that wind up with that barrel up
over their shoulder
and then there are some guys like
winsfield george brad
guys that's finished with the barrel
under their shoulder
but if you see mantle or mays or aaron
or the great fly ball hitters guys that
hit
home runs rodriguez um and mccovey
they all finished with the barrel above
the shoulder
and then the guys that that hit the ball
and put it in place so much
like tony nguyen and karoo they finished
it with the barrel below the shoulder
it's not an upswing you got to learn to
find the ball first
with the barrel before you start
swinging up it's crazy that they
they teach that what do you make reg of
the uh
checking of the pitchers these days you
know i think it well i think
i think it's i think i think it's crazy
i i i don't like it i
uh and and i'm not a i'm not an against
the commissioner guy
right uh i think they're trying to do
the best they can
but what bothers me is when they went
back a few years ago
the analytics talked about spin rate
we got the spin rate we got the spin
rate it's the same way
um you you know when when you take a
look at
at some of the other things that they
talk about in the game that they
feel they have figured out well if you
put a little pine tar
on the ball your spin rate's going to
get better
i mean and that's old news because in my
era guys would use a little pine tar put
it in the stripe on their pants
or put it inside their belt uh you know
where you
you put your pants together and your
your belt goes under you
stick your thumb inside and you got it
you can put your take your fingers and
get a little bit
and it's almost like was was
acknowledged that okay
it's a cold day here in the spring guys
probably using a little pine tar
okay but as far as what they're doing
now
is it cheating yes um
but you know during a time the pine tar
that was an additive for stick and
for a better grip um it was used
but you know what they're doing now is
somewhat of an
embarrassment and the problem i have
with it
is the analytics talk about how they
have increased the spin rate
that's my disappointment with it
yeah i mean it's just it's unfortunate
just seeing pitch and i was somebody to
say
let's get the spider tac that sort of
industrial strength
material that building contractors use
like let's get that out of the game
like but and now that's leading to you
know
pitchers taking their pants off you know
like it's just well
they brought they brought it on
themselves so
they brought it on themselves but i
believe is what the analytics have done
trying to promote spin
i need to tell people about spin right
well we asked nolan ryan and burke
blythe and steve carlton
and bob gibson bobby gibson about spin
rates
they'll tell you about spin rates but
it's
it's it's so sad for me to see them take
to see the analytical people take credit
for it
um i i went to see some of our hitters
once in the minor leagues with the
yankees
and i got back and the general manager
said how to go i said great he said well
people were concerned about what you
were going to tell the hitters
i said really he said yes i said
that makes me sick to my stomach
embarrassing
i need to define what i'm going to tell
a hitter
really and the guy that asked it
and said it runs it right ran the
hitting for the
yankees and never played it down never
touched the ball
never took a snap couldn't tie a pair of
spikes
never played what were they what were
they afraid of what you'd say to the
hitters french
i have no idea so i said to to
i said to someone at a high level i said
for someone to question me about
hitting when i was in the top five
all time of post-season pressure
performers
and i said you want to know what else
not only was i in the top five i wasn't
number three
four or five and somebody asked me a
question about hitting
i just kind of laughed and chuckled when
i got done saying the great reggie
jackson baseball hall of famer here on
the rich eisen show
uh reg last one if you'll indulge me
here
this is when i said at the top that
you're the reason why i started loving
baseball
you know the year before you came in 76
the yankees got swept by the big red
machine and you know chambliss going
yard
and making the world series definitely
got my attention but you you had me at
hello and the reason why i fell in love
with the sport
can you tell me about the night of
october 18th 1977
the the game in which you wrapped up the
world series essentially yourself with
three swings
and three home runs what your mindset
was arriving in the old yankee stadium
that night you know when i went to the
ballpark that day i knew it was game six
and i never really liked to play i was
in game couple game fives with oakland
game sevens with oakland
uh i never liked the game to go to the
seventh game or the fifth game
or the finals because then you'd leave
the chance of
an umpire missing a call a bad bounce
somebody having a fluke good day um
and uh so i always worked hardest in the
sixth game of something when you had a
seven
um i didn't want to lose control and so
when i went to the ballpark i had this
unbelievable batting practice i always
hit last
you know when the two field teams came
on the field the stadium was full in the
world series
and i hit the last five minutes and i
probably hit
took 50 swings and hit 40 balls in the
seats
within a 50 feet radius in right center
when i walked out of the batting cage
and it was three four
deep with crowd around the media around
the cage
i got a standing ovation from the crowd
and i said to
uh dave anderson the great sports writer
with the times
and um dick young
the great writer and host jim
murray from the los angeles times i said
both three of them they were watching
they said boy reggie what an exhibition
i said yeah
i hope i didn't leave it here
you did not i hope it's there later and
uh sure enough
it was there and i tell you on the last
home run
um uh i was sitting in the on deck
circle
and i saw them go to the mound and bring
in charlie huff
right knuckleball i looked i looked
around the stadium
and in my career i probably already had
15 homers off knuckleballers
wilbur wood uh negro
[Music]
hoyt wilhelm eddie fisher steve hargan
i had a million hello a lot of homers
and i looked around they said they must
not no they must not know i hit
knuckleball and the first pitch he threw
man i hit that ball 500 feet
i want to swing and get out of there
before they found out
reggie jackson uh uh i was um
uh eight years old that night and if you
had told that eight-year-old that uh
a day i would turn 52 i'd have a tv
radio show with my name on it and reggie
jackson would call in and wish me happy
birthday i would have cried
i'm not lying man um so this is
as always the greatest you sir i
consider you my friend
i'm right back at you and so does my
wife susie uh adores you reg
and this means the world it really does
thank you so much
yes yes susie slusher suzy shuster
schuster
yeah you married her i knew her before
you married her i know that reg
and she and she knew and she she lorded
that over my head
yeah your childhood idol and then i are
tight i'm like okay
good to know and now the fact that i get
to call you friend as well happy
75th to you belatedly reg thank you so
much happy 52nd to you thank you we'll
talk again
soon and say hello to you to your wife
susie i will do that thanks again reg
you're the best okay my friend ladies
and gentlemen reginald
martinez jackson
greatest nickname in sports mr october
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here